we have a special guest in studio uh
let's jump to christian
thank you yasser yes we are indeed with
christopher you another victor of other
round who bested uh brandon jacobson
christopher first of all welcome to the
show welcome back to st louis uh tell us
a little bit about this game how did you
approach it
i think i just wanted to play
like the main line opening
and i thought he would do something a
little bit you know offbeat because he
usually ends up playing a bit of an
offbeat line
so that's sort of what he did but i
didn't exactly expect the line that he
chose but i knew that it shouldn't be
too good
well he's a very tactical player and
very fast player but
you managed to take the game into a very
strategical territory
were you happy with the outcome of the
opening
yeah and when did you feel like you're
taking over the initiative
i think once i
played knight takes b6 and got rid of
the bishop the position felt very nice
for me
excellent let's keep going through the
game you managed to plant this rook on a
d5 and it seemed like at this point you
just have full control over the position
now how did you assess this particular
end game
like how we know you're better right but
how much better did you think you are
i almost felt like i was winning winning
at this point and the engine actually
agrees with you it seems like you are
almost plus four
at this point a tremendous advantage
and uh did you feel like he was coming
back into the game at any point or did
you feel like you have full control of
the game it felt like i had
full control
yeah excellent
and after g4
beautiful game uh christopher i have to
say a tremendous start for you against
one of the main rivals in this
tournament brandon jacobson who do you
have tomorrow
a wonderliang oh another big one with
the black pieces
well that one is going to be a clash for
the ages go get some rest go get your
preparation and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you